[__]
[Laughter]
you're literally the dumbest person
what is this
[Music]
we are moving in the subscription
paywall digital age like for cars and
everything for cars and everything
exactly cars cars Mercedes dude you
haven't heard of this Mercedes has just
heated seats and [__] you gotta pay pay
wall that [__] even though it's
available
I'm sorry Mercedes locks faster
acceleration behind a 1200 annual
payment oh my God no faster acceleration
weird so your car is capable but you
have to pay to unlock the future that's
[__] weird we're gonna do computers
like this soon it's going to be wild on
computers yeah think about it it's like
oh well your computer has all this
access to like extra storage but you got
to pay more to like
what a [__] scam that is that's the
description model dude I'm gonna buy
only old cars man for real God damn this
is what's the point yeah but then if you
have an old car that's not electric the
government's gonna like charge you extra
or some [__] watch God damn there's no
more gas stations it's all a racket dude
no because like if you want heat your
car like has heated seats but you can't
access them unless you pay 30 months or
whatever and then it turns on so the
1200 yearly subscription improves
performance by boosting output from the
motors by 20 to 24
increasing torque and shaving around 0.8
to 0.9 seconds off of the 0 to 60. it's
a lot really it's gonna happen right
okay black box they're just gonna make a
firmware that jailbreaks it yup that's
tight always and Ryan's going to be the
first guy in there I respect but I bet
you if you do it then let Voyager
warrants oh for sure oh yeah they'll
break your [__] car who gives a [__]
you know they'll just they're always
going to be a workaround just like key
gens you hit I agree that means we can
brick your car because you did this [__]
it's no different than voiding a
warranty like um you want to open up
your PS5 and then you have a problem
with it well guess what they find out
you tampered with it no warranty [__]
you yeah but as long as it's electronic
I feel like that's why white hats are
going to come in and [__] fix that
someone's gonna find a way what's up
with this [__] why can't they just
[__] make money The Honorable way
where give me sell me something sick and
I'll pay full price yeah pistol I mean
historically there's compromise always
wins like in in terms of like when they
made music inaccessible and then
everyone just started napstering the the
comp the Great Compromise happened of
like okay we can't sue everybody's doing
this we can't break everybody's shoes so
let's find a middle ground yeah I think
they're just starting off with this
because that's the power play and then
there's gonna be a backlash and then
they're gonna go okay okay well how
about this and if you remember they they
made sure to make an example out of some
people right like Napster yeah like
those poor people you think they're in
jail oh dude some random people got like
sued for millions of dollars just some
random ass Blue Collar person just goes
down big time and they're like put it on
the news big headline if you do this
this could happen to you scares people
Silk Road same [__] that guy went away
right they're doing with some crypto
people same [__] yeah it's just it's the
model and then like you said the Great
Compromise happens like as they figure
out where they want to be regulatory
wise well it makes sense for the Great
Compromise for the auto mobile industry
it depends how good the [__] hacking
is like if people can hack the [__] out
of it to where they're powerless which
has happened historically with most
things that are electronic hackers
eventually win because there's too many
of them and they're looking around the
[__] clock you know this has its
Global sales for new cars have fallen in
recent years car manufacturers have
pivoted towards selling software updates
and features as subscriptions to
generate a continuous Revenue stream
long after a car has been purchased
while this makes sense for certain
software specific offerings such as
premium navigation features or remote
vehicle monitoring Mercedes pay Walling
its vehicle performance is part of an
emerging more loathsome Trend that sees
Auto Brands restricting the capabilities
of Hardware that already comes Factory
equipped with the vehicle I remember
something like this more in like the 90s
and early 2000s remember they had like
Governors on cars yeah so like American
cars like Chevys and Fords or whatever
like you can only go up to like 85 or
90. but that's only because that car is
in California so if you bought the same
exact car and it's like in Arizona or
something then you can go full like 150
or whatever but you didn't have to pay
to unlock it that was just the law of
the state so that they make the car
based on the laws of the state to pay to
unlock is [__] here yeah was it
called chipped or something yeah it's
chipped yeah you could chip it and you
could like unlock it or whatever it's
like having a skylight that you can't
like doing it's like just sitting there
but like you can't open it up because
you didn't pay yeah it's [__] weird
even though you paid for it yeah even
when remember when DVD players were a
big thing to have in your car there was
a there was a lock that didn't let you
watch it when you were driving oh yeah
the same guy that installs it can also
disable that yeah just like with
California water when they put your
[__] shower head in there's a water
conservation right in between the pipe
and then lets less water out you asked
the same guy hey can you take that out
sure that's as easy as that that gets
like you know what I mean everyone who
can administer these different
Electronics or anything with regulations
are the same people that cannot do it
too they're The Gatekeepers exactly what
not to bring it up but water pressure
Nevada way better
just Sands make me a pipeline make me a
pipeline please no Nikki Nikki who's
last night was just she's just taking a
shower at the hotel and she's like the
waterproof is [__] horrible here and
I'm like yeah and the drips they're
saving the drips on you well it's half
water and half taxes
you know what's funny is that water
comes from Nevada too here
yeah well it comes from Lake Mead and
Hoover Dam yeah I don't know that like
Lake Mead Southern California a bunch of
the Southwest no [__] that's why people
The Californians are laughing at Nevada
look at Lake Mead I might do that short
water too yeah a lot of it is them oh
because it's like getting dry oh got it
so I think they're just trying to find
ways to go oh California's still better
but it's like no we're all kind of in
this together dude I would never talk
[__] about Lake Mead man was it like me
is it like me being diverted too like
that's part of why the water levels have
gone down
I was just reading some [__] about it
[__] by the way Nevada has incredible
water conservation yep that's why
um the the so the Colorado River tell
this guy this guy hates Nevada
why you eat it
I don't believe 911.
clip it clip it
he's at it he said it dead to rights you
know it's funny he's like these things
are obviously directed to the common
person that doesn't know how to do a
workaround and I think if there's enough
of them that they don't complain they
just pay for it yeah this will probably
fly but then with things like let's say
Adobe when Adobe became subscription
based all the people that were hacking
it it didn't affect them at all to this
day are still using all the Adobe
products I do think Adobe the adobe's
food is cool yeah because instead of
dropping like I don't know like a
thousand bucks on like five programs now
it's it's like eight dollars yeah yeah
no it's not it's a subscription is the
[__] updates
I've been using Photoshop like a dream
for years and then all of a sudden they
do an update now and even when I go to
save it they're like do you want to save
it as like like cloud-based [__] I'm
like what the [__] guys what'd you do
and then uh so you know you used to
control t stretch an image or whatever
the [__] now you control T it's like
it's like wobbling all over the place
I'm like no it used to
just control teak
it got the consistent and now it's all
[__] I don't even know what I'm doing
I hate these guys you have to like hold
like option or control at the same time
or I don't have an apple [__] I have a
TPC yeah
PCS shift you [__] I doubt literally a
[__] idiot you little man
[Laughter]
so I was quoting Glenn Gary Glen Ross
for like the last like 90 seconds
that wasn't even Steve Green yeah that's
that's what I think is like people will
pay for when it's when it's convenient
and easy they'll pay for the legit thing
only when it's convenient and easy yep
and that's how it should be because
sometimes it's too much of a pain in the
ass to hack some [__] then you won't do
it oh I'll just pay for it oh you're
right you know how to hack Adobe sweet
you anybody could just Google how to get
Adobe Ryan's probably gonna answer
anything like anybody could when really
just Ryan knows how to do it no it's
like if anyone can make nuclear missiles
Ryan or it's like hey but hey Google
don't Google that don't Google that yeah
you'll end up until I had a discount
with a worker that has
connects like at Adobe and they gave me
a discount for like whatever all of my
[__] was pirated because it was just
easier yeah you'd be surprised how many
professional musicians are running
pirated software yeah melodyne Ableton
most most professional musician [__] is
not [__] legit dude final draft
because they're that they're just that
Savvy they're just like why buy it and
he Premiere then I need Premiere I need
to not pay for that you know what's
Chris David so when you when you open it
right just [__] type in the key
there's hackers I've already made key
gens like you hit it once and it goes
type these six numbers in that doesn't
work type V6 numbers in because usually
when I type in when I see the [__]
the the the the dialogue box that says
hey type in your [__] key code and
I'm like ah [__] you get a key gen thing
that's that's the problem I think with
with the business model is starting to
charge people things that they're not
used to paying for just like Elon musk's
thing he's rolling that back yeah well
the Eight dollar Twitter's not offline
like even that why and you think about
how like absolute that was when it came
out but it's not it's probably gonna pay
for it if no one's gonna do it then
they're just gonna think of a compromise
you guys want to know my little hack
what
I don't even pay for internet
so check this out allegedly how do you
do that so I moved into my neighborhood
right yeah yeah I'm gonna make it good
with the neighbors and [__] you go to
the house oh hey what's your Wi-Fi let
me keep their Wi-Fi
put this [__] and putting [__] in
there for Wi-Fi my neighbor pays for my
[__] internet that's what do you do
you get a extender you got a Wi-Fi
extender Wi-Fi extenders all through my
house
and you get and you got all your devices
only on one side of the house every one
of my [__] plugs with a Wi-Fi
extender
oh my God save it on the subscription
part that's what I [__] you dude they
doubled my [__] internet his Wi-Fi
extenders have subscriptions
it's at like 80 bucks a month dude my
internet went from like [__] 45 a
month to like 90 a month
[Laughter]
thank you thank you very much and then
Nick's like oh just making good deals
babe that's what I'm doing making good
deals I'm a businessman gonna make it
cost more now for our car hold on
I don't see the subscription [__]
lasting for cars it seems like a meme
right I don't see it last is it it's not
logical it's like if I already bought
the material now you're gonna charge me
for something that already exists that's
weird but the great the Great Compromise
could work uh like Ryan was saying
though it's like um I would pay Adobe
like x amount of money per year to keep
using the program If instead of paying
like 600 bucks for the program I only
had to pay like 20 bucks to get it yeah
and then I have to pay a subscription to
keep it because that's what they did
with iPhones now everyone with iPhones
it's always like oh I only paid like 40
bucks a month instead of paying a
thousand but but you're like oh but your
contract lasts three years and you have
to stick with them yeah you know what I
mean and it's like so it's the same [__]
so I could see that same thing I would
totally get a Mercedes if you're like
hey you can get this Mercedes off the
lot for 500 bucks
you just got to pay monthly XYZ I might
be like that's a better deal yeah by the
way I was just in the Volkswagen EV to
when the Nancy's made
how to make a fine out of them wow they
made the Volkswagen right but the
Volkswagen EV I was just in it
doesn't ask he's got some good science
honestly one of the best rides it's
smooth really nice is it SUV or is this
sedan it was an SUV it was [__] nice
too yeah it looks cool would you say
that Nazis make a great product I think
the Nazis make good highways Bridges
freeways is this on patreon
about this one